Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a British psychological thriller film
called “Exam.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the movie, eight candidates
are shown getting ready for a hiring examination
for a profitable corporate job. Some candidates
motivate themselves with encouraging words,
while some add a few touch-ups to their
appearances before moving to the examination
hall. The place is dimly lit with desks for every
candidate kept uniformly throughout the room.
It also has cameras to monitor their activities.
After the eight of them are seated, a guard with a
gun enters the room, visibly making the candidates
nervous. He is followed by a man who doesn’t tell
them his name and simply introduces himself as the
invigilator. He then apologizes to them for the
hardships they have faced to reach this room,
revealing that the candidates have passed
all the previous hiring processes and are
the finalists. If they pass this last test, they
will be getting the jobs of their dreams.
As the “rule” of the test, the
invigilator claims that no federal law
applies inside the examination hall and the
candidates are supposed to follow only the law
of the exam. They are not allowed to communicate
with the guard or the invigilator. Similarly, if
they ruin the paper intentionally or accidentally
and if they walk out of the room for any reason,
they will be disqualified. The candidate will have
eighty minutes to complete the test. There is only
one question on the paper before them that they
need to answer. The invigilator then asks them if
they have any questions. When no one answers, he
wishes them luck, starts the timer, and walks out.
The candidates turn their respective papers
around and see that it is completely blank.
All of them look at each other in confusion.
As time passes, they get more nervous. Hence,
candidate number two starts writing on her paper
why she thinks she is eligible for the job. The
camera in the room zooms into her paper and
the guard is told to throw her out because she
ruined her paper. Number two begs for a second
chance as the guard locks the doors on her.
A while later, number five realizes that the
rule says they cannot talk to the invigilator
and the guard, which means they can talk to
each other. He tells the others the same thing,
making them believe that they will have to
work together to find what the question is
before they find the answer. The group
discusses several ways they can pass the test,
but all of them are just as confused. Throughout
this, candidate number one doesn’t speak at all.
One man tries to introduce himself but number five
suggests they give each other pet names so they
wouldn’t have to reveal their true identity.
He goes on to name candidate number one,
Deaf because he hasn’t spoken yet. Then,
the guys are named brown, black, and white
according to their race, and the girls are named
blonde, brunette, and dark, according to their
hair color. After that, White suggests they get
up from their seats because there is no such rule
that says that cannot. He takes a chance and gets
up. To everyone's delight, the guard stays put,
meaning that they can move around freely. Dark
believes that the questions are written down
on paper with invisible ink or a watermark. They
all agree to test the theory but do not know how
to. Dark then gets up and uses the lights in the
room to see if something is written on the paper.
However, nothing is visible. She still
insists everyone check their own because
the question could be in just one of them.
Everyone does as she says except for Deaf who
stays quietly in his seat. White takes his paper
and checks it in the light. When they do not get
any results, Black suggests the writings might
be visible in UV rays or x-rays. The group then
starts looking for a switchboard to see if there
is an option to turn on other kinds of lights.
When they do not find one, they start to
look for the source of such light themselves.
Deaf doesn’t help them whatsoever and nervously
stays on his seat. Blonde finds strips of
emergency lights in the room. But since there are
no switches, the group has to break all the other
light bulbs to create an emergency and trigger the
lights. Brown retaliates saying that they cannot
take such a risk. So, they vote on the matter and
eventually decide to go forth with the plan.
After breaking all the light bulbs
in the room, it suddenly glows blue
because of the emergency black light. Everyone
starts to look for the question in the paper,
except for Deaf. But they are disappointed
again because they cannot see the question.
Brunette asks everyone to remove the first layer
of the strip light because they aren’t lit.
This might give rise to UV rays which can
help them. They use the woman’s heels to
break the strips and reveal another form
of light. However, they are again met with
disappointment because these lights do not work
either. Now the group only has sixty minutes left.
A frustrated White asks everyone to think of
alternatives. As they brainstorm ideas, White
registers that they can do anything to number
2’s paper since she is already disqualified.
So, they gather around her desk and try tracing
the paper with a pencil. Still, no question comes
forth. White then tears her paper into sections
so that they can use them to experiment with
different methods. Next, he pees on one of
the papers to see if it is liquid-activated.
However, that doesn’t work either. Black and
White get into a heated argument while discussing
what they should do next but they stop after
hearing Deaf cry. He sobs silently in his seat
while the others watch him in amusement. After
that, the man starts to blabber in French. He
asks them if they can see something in the paper
and claims that the paper reflects their image.
They do not think much about his blabberings
and get back into discussing ideas.
Everyone falls dead silent when Brown speaks. He
proposes a theory of his own claiming that they
are not in an exam but are in some kind of betting
show. The board members of the company have placed
bets on who will crack under pressure and the
sole purpose of them being there is for their
entertainment. Dark thinks that the board members
probably have better things to do with their time
but according to Brown, money is the least of
their concerns. With the amount of money they have
in their life, the board members probably live
for the risks. Now, everyone comes forward with
their own ideas. Some claim that the invigilator
might be behind this while others say it might
be the CEO. They begin to crack under pressure
and insult each other. Brunette confidently says
that there are no people watching them because the
CEO is hands-on in the company. He has all of the
company’s rights and power over everyone.
It is clear that she knows more about the
company than anyone else. Brown asks her how she
knows so much about the CEO. It turns out that
Brunette is already working for the company
in HR but has never seen the CEO. She applied
for a higher job and now she is here.
White then reveals that he was headhunted
and offered the job. But the others say that they
applied for it. However, one thing they have in
common is that they do not know anything
about the company and what it does because
they were told not to ask any questions.
Brunette then explains that they are applying
for a famous multi-million Pharmaceutical company
called Birog. A few years ago when a pandemic
spread among young people of the world, they
were the first ones to find the cure. Currently,
their yearly turnover is $20 billion dollars, all
because of their CEO. Suddenly, Black suggests
that the company might have found a cure to
the newest deadly disease that has been killing
millions of people around the world. Dark is
suddenly intrigued and asks Black more about it.
This makes White suspicious, so he asks
Dark if she is also infected by the virus.
Dark says she isn’t and dismisses the
matter. To take the attention off her,
she approaches the guard and brings a lighter
out of his pocket without talking to him.
Then, she glances at the fire alarm. The
group plans to use the lighter to trigger
the sprinkler because water can potentially
develop the writings on the paper. For this,
Dark gets on top of a chair but doesn’t reach
the fire alarm. White helps her by giving her
a rolled piece of paper that she lights up and
uses to trigger the alarm. Soon, water starts
showering but the papers stay the same. Suddenly,
the guard makes his way to the group. Right then,
Dark unfolds the paper in her hand and reveals it
to be her own. White had betrayed her to loosen
the competition. The guard drags Dark away
as she calls White a bastard. Following that,
an enraged Black says he will punch white
lights out. This makes the lights go out and
the group figures they are voice-activated.
They ask each other to be careful with what
they say when Deaf starts to cry again. White
slyly sits in front of him and bullies the poor
guy into tearing his own paper and eating it. The
guard approaches Deaf and sends him away as well.
Now only five of the candidates are left. Black
belittles White for being an awful person but
white insists they should thank him for getting
their competitors out. He also claims that he
knows what the question is but refuses to tell
the others. In a fit of rage, Black knocks him
out with a single punch. The group then ties
him to a seat and covers his mouth with a tie.
A while later, White gains consciousness. Brunette
removes his gag and he asks for his medication,
saying that he is also infected with the virus and
has to take medicine every hour for him to live.
Back searches for pills in his pocket but doesn’t
find one. This makes the group believe that White
is just making excuses so they would free
him. However, White claims that one of them
has taken the pill and promises to tell them
what the question is if they give it back.
Soon, he loses consciousness again and starts
to tremble. Some believe he is faking but Balck
says that he is getting a seizure because of the
virus. They start looking for the pill he was
talking about but cannot find it in the room. With
only fifteen minutes left on the timer, they check
each other for the pill. Brunette suspects Brown
for taking it and is proven right when she finds
the pill stuck to a chewing gum under his table.
She tries to feed it to white but Brown throws it
into a vent. As the others try to get it out, a
stressed Brunette goes in front of the camera and
asks the invigilator to save the man. But since
she talked to the invigilator, she is immediately
disqualified. After she is gone, Blonde brings the
pill out with a bobby pin and saves White’s life.
She also unties him in the process.
After he recovers, everyone asks him for
the answer he promised. White reveals that the
answers are the candidates themselves. They
have been searching for a question all this time
but White thinks that there is no question and
the one who is left at the end is the answer. The
rest of them believe him but before they can act,
White runs to get the gun from the guard. Black
pushes him aside and acquires the gun himself.
He points it at White who confidently claims
that he won’t shoot anyone. Simultaneously,
he attacks Black and gets the gun. However, when
he is about to use it he realizes the gun has
fingerprint recognition. So, White uses the guard
and points the gun at the others. He threatens
everyone to get out of the room on their own so he
can win the position. Brown doesn’t retaliate with
the fear of being shot and deliberately walks
out. A scared blonde slowly walks outside but
yells “lights out” at the end. The room goes pitch
dark making White shoot in random directions.
When the lights come back, Black falls limp on the
floor with a bullet hole on his chest. White looks
around and sees Blonde still has a foot inside the
room. He is about to shoot her as well but notices
that the timer has stopped. Now, White walks
to the camera and tells the invigilator that he
is the winner of the competition. The guard
approaches him and shows him the time. White
is in shock to see they still have twenty seconds
left, meaning that he is disqualified for talking
to the invigilator. It is then revealed that
Deaf had changed the time when they were busy
discussing other things. At last, the only one
left is blonde. She walks into the room and picks
up Deaf’s glasses that had fallen while he was
being taken out. Using those, she looks at the
paper and sees “question 1” written on it.
To her uttermost surprise, Deaf enters the
room revealing that he is the CEO of the company
and was in the test to keep an eye on everyone.
Blonde walks up to him and says “no”. The CEO and
the invigilator smile, seeing that she has figured
out the question and passed the test. It turns
out when the invigilator asked them “if they had
any questions” at the beginning of the test,
it was the only question they had to answer.
The whole exam was set to test the candidates’
intelligence and attentiveness. They hire Blonde
as the CEO’s secretary but she doesn’t accept
the job because she doesn’t want to work with
an organization that kills people. The invigilator
reveals that Black isn’t really dead and that the
bullet he got hit with is a capsule that heals
the wound after penetrating the body. It is
actually the magical medicine they have recently
manufactured which can cure any disease in the
world. At last, Blonde accepts the job and the
movie ends as she shakes hands with the CEO.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on the notification,
and leave a like to help the channel out.
Thanks for watching.